CBS News has just learned the
Transportation Security Administration
is taking emergency action on air cargo
from five predominantly Muslim countries
it is part of an effort to stay ahead of
potential terror plots targeting
aircraft the new order covers all US
bound commercial and cargo flights from
seven airports in Egypt Jordan Qatar
Saudi Arabia and the United Arab
Emirates six airlines are affected Kris
Van Cleave is breaking this story today
he is a Dulles International Airport
outside Washington Chris good morning
five of those airlines serve Washington
Dulles and while all cargo bound for the
US is screened growing concern about
terrorists sneaking a bomb onto an
airplane is prompting this emergency
order from the TSA administrator that's
going to require airlines to provide
additional specific information about
all cargo they plan to bring into
America information like where a package
is coming from who sent it how it was
sent where it has it been since it's
been mailed where it's going and its
contents tsa says its goal is to spot
shipments that are out of the ordinary
and this order gives the TSA and customs
time and authority to have an airline do
further screening if something appears
amiss a TSA official told CBS News these
countries were chosen because of a
demonstrated intent by terrorist groups
to attack aviation from them this is all
Intel driven that Intel continues to
center around bombs hidden in large
electronic devices that may be able to
get past some screening equipment
something that's already prompted
increased security at airports worldwide
also Intel from a foiled attack in
Australia over the summer where a
military-grade explosive was sent via
air cargo from Turkey continues to drive
concern Turkey is the only other country
required to participate in this advanced
screening program other airlines do
voluntarily but the TSA says the Trump
administration is now considering making
that program mandatory Gail thank you
very much Chris Van Cleve